die kolleginnen und kollegen am
vergangenen freitag hat ein mitglied
dieses hauses nachdem wir von der
amtierenden präsidentin das wort erteilt
worden war versucht aus anlass des
fürchterlichen mordes an einem
14-jährigen mädchen durch demonstrative
schweigen eine art schweigeminute
herbeizuführen
nach unserer geschäftsordnung wird
abgeordnete das wort erteilt damit sie
zur sache sprechen können die water
teilung bedeutet nicht dass der
abgeordneten das wort erteilt wurde über
seine redezeit frei verfügen darf
christoph wortbeiträge beschränkt
unabhängig davon liegt es in der
kompetenz des präsidenten über
schweigeminuten und gedenken den er
vertritt nach paragraf 7 absatz 1 der
geschäftsordnung den deutschen bundestag
präsidium oder ältestenrat sind gremien
für entsprechende anregungen von seiten
der fraktion ein einzelner abgeordneter
auf den bundestag nicht durch einen
eigenmächtigen aufruf zu einer
schweigeminute für seine zwecke
vereinnahmen wollen auch nicht eine
einzelne fraktion entsprechender die
amtierende präsidentin die kollegin
claudia roth claudia roth am vergangenen
freitag den abgeordneten wiederholt zur
sache gerufen und nachdem man dem nicht
gefolgt ist ihn aufgefordert das
rednerpult zu verlassen
unmittelbar nach dem vorfall im
plenarsaal wurde auf den seiten der fdp
fraktion in einem sozialen netzwerk in
deren impressum die kollegin dr weidl
und der kollege dr gauland aufgeführt
werden
ein video des vorgangs veröffentlicht
und mit folgenden worten kommentiert ich
zitiere ansehen und teilen entlarvende
reaktionen seitens claudia roth und der
anderen fraktionen soeben nutzte die afg
fraktion die gelegenheit der in
wiesbaden von einem abgelehnten
asylbewerber getöteten zu seiner 14 im
bundestag zu gedenken
lediglich die fdp fraktion beteiligt ist
sicherer als sitzungspräsident claudia
roth
ignoriere die schweigeminute und verwies
thomas seitz afd vom rednerpult
soweit das zitat in der folge wurde vize
präsidentin roth in dem sozialen
netzwerk in zahllosen kommentaren in e
mails und telefonischen anrufen
verleumdet beleidigt und bedroht zum
teil auf eine weise die mich veranlasst
hat polizeiliche schutzmaßnahmen für sie
prüfen zu lassen
die inszenierung vom vergangenen freitag
hatte nicht nur die beschriebenen
persönlichkeitsverletzungen zur folge
sie betrifft auch das verfassungsorgan
deutscher bundestag mit dessen würde ist
es nicht vereinbar wenn auch nur der
anschein der instrumentalisierung der
opfer von verbrechen entsteht
in meiner rede zur konstituierenden
sitzung des bundestags habe ich gesagt
dass wir als abgeordnete des ganzen
volkes im sinne von artikel 38
grundgesetz eine vielzahl von interessen
meinungen und befindlichkeiten mit den
begrenzten unter endlichkeit der
realität zusammenbringen müssen da ist
streit nicht nur erlaubt es geht nur
über streit den müssen wir führen und
den müssen wir aushalten ertragen
demokratischer streit ist notwendig auch
leidenschaftlicher und auch polemischer
streit wenn sie mich weiter unterbrechen
ruf ist die zuordnung
[Applaus]
aber dieser streit ist ein streit nach
regeln und er ist mit der bereitschaft
verbunden die demokratischen verfahren
zu achten
es gehört es gehört zu unserer
verantwortung dass wir aus der erfahrung
unserer geschichte lernen wie leicht
verantwortungsloser streit zu hass und
einer eskalation von gewalt führen kann
was wir hier sagen damit häufig die
zuordnung was wir hier sagen und wie wir
uns verhalten hat folgen auch für die
öffentliche debatte in unserer
gesellschaft
es kann vorbildlich seien für eine
zivilisierte auseinandersetzung es kann
aber auch anlass sein für hass und hetze
für verrohung bis hin zu schlimmsten
formen von gewalt wir müssen maßhalten
um unser politisches und
gesellschaftliches klima nicht zu
vergiften
zum wohle des deutschen volkes das zu
vertreten nur beauftragt sind
[Applaus]